bonsoir à tous je m'appelle julia et
j'ai 21 ans je suis d'origine arménienne
et si je suis né et j'ai grandi à nice
depuis tout petit j'ai été baigné dans
la convivialité il partage des repas de
famille ma mère était la reine de la
ratatouille et adonis hausse lui le papa
de ma marraine lui était pâtissier et
j'allais souvent faire des gâteaux
immense avec eux
sauf que je passais plus de temps à
goûter les préparations qu'à les aider
réellement
il me racontait toujours des anecdotes
qui me faisait mourir de rire
à l'époque le métier de cuisinier était
très mal payés et les produits comme le
beurre coûtait une fortune alors un jour
un de ses collègues a décidé de cacher
une plaquette de beurre sous sa toque
prêt à rentrer laisse faire un festin à
la maison sauf que là le patron commence
à lui parlé de la nouvelle carte et lui
tient la jambe pendant une heure mais
avec la chaleur le bar commence à fondre
et des collines surtout j'avais dit que
c'était elle ou pas il fallait tout ce
qu'ils avaient pu lui raconter à l'âge
de 13 ans je savais que je voulais faire
de la cuisine et c'était devenu mon
objectif à 14 ans je démarre mossé ap
cuisine en alternance dans un restaurant
gastronomique à nice au bout d'un an
mon chef obtient une étoile je me donne
à fond
j'adore ce que je découvre ses odeurs
ses produits ce vocabulaire bien définis
à cet environnement tout nouveau pour
moi
car oui je vous rassure ans était pas du
tout comme vous aimez imaginer mais on
s'adapte vite à ce monde décalé mais
très excitant
je suis avec des plus vieux mais ils me
font confiance à leurs côtés j'apprends
tous les jours j'apprends la cuisine
bien sûr mais j'apprends la vie aussi
les premières sorties en boîte dans les
bars etc
en 2011 je participe au concours des
meilleurs apprentis de france
j'obtiens la médaille d'or régionale et
puis pour la finale je monte sur paris
mais j'en garde pas un très bon souvenir
ont été montés très tôt avec mon chef
le déroulement était un peu compliqué je
m'étais mis une pression de dingue
un peu comme ça
bon résultat au final c'était la cata
résultat en finale c'était la cata mais
c'était très formateur
une expérience unique auprès de mon
maître d'apprentissage qui a pris du
temps pour me faire aller encore plus
loin et puis c'est en tant qu on apprend
à se relever et j'en sors grandi je
commence alors une nouvelle année
d'apprentissage cette fois en pâtisserie
au bout de trois ans je dois évoluer
voir autre chose du coup je décide de
monter sur paris mais là la galère
commence parce que je suis mineur et
pour trouver du boulot c'est pas facile
mais j'arrive à décrocher un entretien
et le courant passe bien pourtant le
premier récit n'est pas une réussite
le restaurant était un changement de
chef des jets mais c est ça ne me
correspond toujours pas aller le
troisième sera le bon et je commence
enfin mon aventure au restaurant les
fables de la fontaine située dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris j'obtiens mon
premier boulot à 17 ans je commence
comme une cuisine six mois après je suis
demi chef de partie
un an après sous-chef les grades dans
une cuisine sont établis comme ceci du
moins gradés jusqu'au chef commis de
cuisine de michel deux parties chefs de
partis sous chef chef de cuisine c'est
génial à peine 18 ans et ont nommé
responsable de la cuisine quand le chef
n'est pas là mais j'ai peur peur de pas
être à la hauteur
au début en tout cas c'est la
catastrophe premier jour sans le chef
est sale ou pas je me taille long de
l'index en taillant malade je suis
tellement stressée et juste à ce moment
là évidemment le chef passe nous faire
un petit coucou et voir comment ça se
passe et wii xbox com vous l'aï stock
quand il se rend compte que j'ai un
énorme pansement que j'essayais à tout
prix du kg
bref la journée se passe mal mais je
m'accroche
petit à petit je trouve ma place dans un
restaurant l'équipe c'est une famille et
je suis soutenu de tous alors que je
suis sous chef depuis deux ans mon chef
m'annonce qu'il s'en va et le patron me
nomme comme successeur malgré mon jeune
âge mon implication mon travail ma
disponibilité à tout moment ont fait la
différence
j'ai toujours fait passer mon travail
avant tout ma carrière
la priorité alors le chef on prépare
doucement son départ il met sa main les
clés de sa cuisine les derniers jours ça
nous fait bizarre à tous les deux ont
travaillé main dans la main encore plus
fort que jamais au bout de trois ans de
collaboration
c'est dur de se quitter puis gilad est
mon chef
avec tous les moments géniaux comme
horrible qu'on a vécu au quotidien
c'était devenu mon ami aussi quand il
part en février 2015
nous on parie tout changé depuis
quelques mois le restaurant est en perte
de vitesse
vieillissant alors avec le patron mon
souci est fait mon directeur nous
repensons le positionnement du
restaurant on agrandit la salle on passe
les cuisines en sous sol une cuisine
plus accessible mais qui reste de
qualité une cuisine plus modernes cui
qui reste authentique une cuisine que je
sais et aime faire alors
les travaux lancés on a du temps pour
penser à tous ces changements à notre
future carte pense qu'à ça on a hâte que
le challenge commence la cuisine en
dragons ou on a même fait venir la
photographe chez mon patron pour prendre
les premières photos de plats alors je
commence à fait un bep cuisine dans son
appartement avec le matériel
professionnel réduit c'est du tout
terrain je mets mes points de décoration
sur les assiettes avec une seringue que
j'ai trouvé dans sa boîte à pharmacie
fond c'est n'importe quoi mais c'est des
moments inoubliables et réouverture le 3
août
des couacs au début et c'est normal le
temps se faire assez de cuisine neuve
est complètement réaménager la salle
avec beaucoup de plus espace le premier
service nous on essaie avec les machines
à bons de commande
c'est la catastrophe les tickets
n'arrête pas de défilé et je sais plus
où donner de la tête
on passe du gaz à l'induction alors je
vous laisse imaginer les premiers ratés
bref on revient à l'ancienne méthode et
les serveurs nous emmène directement les
banques commando cuisine est assez vite
la sauce prend on prend nos marques et
ça commence à rouler on prend du temps
avec nos équipes et en salle qu'en
cuisine
le personnel se sent bien et rentre dans
le défi avec nous du restaurant
gastronomique où on ne perd pas un bras
quand on paye l'addition
et voilà nous sommes le 1er février 2016
six mois après la l'ouverture et je
pense que je me souviendrai toute ma vie
de cette date
mon patron s'est agenouillé devant moi
en plein service un bouquet de fleurs à
la main alors non il ne demandait pas en
mariage mais il était en train de
m'annoncer nous avons obtenu notre
première étoile au guide michelin
big up les patins à portet
à cet instant je suis devenue la chef
étoilée la plus jeune de france alors
que c'est mon sous-chef était comme
d'habitude est en train de charrier en
me disant qu'il irait acheter une étoile
en carton la quincaillerie bref je suis
tellement fier fier de ce qu'on a
réalisé en si peu de temps
fier de mon équipe qui a passé
énormément de temps à nos côtés
aujourd'hui on est largement récompensés
mais en fait cette étoile
on n'a pas obtenu en six mois mais pour
ma part belle est bien moins huit ans
depuis que j'ai posé un pied en cuisine
c'est un combat de tous les jours
oui je suis jeune mais j'ai bossé
énormément j'ai fait des sacrifices
c'est un métier avec beaucoup de stress
et beaucoup de pression alors à tous
ceux qui veulent commencer ou qui
commence la restauration
accrochez vous soyez motivé mais soyez
patients tout arrive à point à qui sait
attendre
heureusement j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer les bonnes personnes
les personnes qui m'ont fait confiance
les personnes qui m'ont accompagné et
soutenu et aujourd'hui j'ai à coeur de
reproduire ce schéma
j'ai seulement 21 ans mais je sais que
la relève est déjà là quelque part alors
à mon tour de faire confiance